the movie begins in a scandinavian
school sixteen-year-old simone is
excited about a presentation she and her
group of friends are preparing they joke
around and laugh unaware of the
catastrophe approaching them suddenly
simone's father frederick pulls her away
from the group and says that she has to
come with him instantly frederick is a
scientist working for a company called
apollon he thinks that the world is
about to end because of an infectious
rainfall that makes people sick and
kills them in minutes the dark clouds
are approaching the city so he puts his
family in the car and drives to a safer
location simone's brother rasmus refuses
to wear his seatbelt which distracts
frederick and causes him to crash into a
vehicle it stops the traffic and blocks
the way frederick knows there isn't much
time left so instead of arguing with the
other drivers he brings his family out
and runs into the woods a man notices
that they are in a hurry and follows
them a while later the family reaches a
bunker made by apollon for emergencies
like this seconds after they get inside
the first drop of rain falls onto a leaf
followed by a heavy rainfall the family
is sanitized by an automated system
before going into the living area the
kids are scared and so are the parents
but they do not show it frederick has to
go out because he might know a way to
stop the spread of the virus before
leaving he tells simone to take care of
her brother because he is the answer to
stopping all this simone doesn't
understand him but frederick doesn't
have time to explain after he leaves she
goes on her phone and watches her
friends die in live streams everyone
outside is terrified of the fast
spreading virus the mother tries to calm
them down by making them hot cocoa but
it is evident that she is just as scared
suddenly they hear a banging on the door
to the bunker their mother knows that
frederick can let himself in so she asks
the kids to ignore it however they are
too impatient and naive they rush to the
door and open it before their mother can
stop them outside the man who saw them
earlier in the traffic is standing in
the rain he pulls rasmus and is visibly
struggling because of the virus the
mother leaps at him and asks the kids to
close the door instantly they do not
want to leave her outside but have to
reluctantly close the door she struggles
and dies while rasmus and simone cry
mourning her death simone takes care of
her brother cheering him up when she can
even though she is hurting too at night
they go to sleep but simone wakes up to
a noise on checking she finds rasmus out
of his bed he says that he saw their
father but simone assumes it was just a
dream following that they find the
control room and discover that there are
more bunkers throughout the city simone
tries to contact them but fails they
also get their hands on the radio and
attempt to communicate with someone
outside the plan works and they get to
talk to a boy named philip he turns out
to be a scared teenager stuck inside his
basement he reveals that all of his
family is dead and tries to help simone
by calling her father however a while
later the connection is lost and the
siblings are left alone once again
simone promises rasmus that their father
will return to them after saving the
world as the two take care of each other
days turn into weeks weeks into months
and months into years the scene cuts to
six years later rasmus has become a 17
year old teenager since he hit puberty
he has been growing more impatient by
the day simone tries her best to be
hopeful but after so many years of their
father's absence she doesn't know if
they will ever get to meet him rasmus
often blames her for lying when she knew
that their father would never return one
night simone decides that she has waited
long enough making sure that rasmus is
asleep she dons a hazmat suit and opens
the door for the first time in six years
if she was going to do something this
rash i wonder what took her so long
suddenly the memory of her mother's
death comes flooding back she tries to
look for her remains but doesn't find
anything she assumes it must have been
eaten by animals and runs towards the
city there are several marks on the
ground showing her the way to the
quarantine zone simone follows them but
only finds decayed corpses it finally
hits her that no one is alive in the
outside world the life before the virus
is history and staying inside the bunker
won't give them anything suddenly a wild
dog chases her and she locks herself in
a room i guess dogs are rain proof the
next morning rasmus wakes up and sees
her in the kitchen she tells him that
she went outside and saw no one they
decide to leave the bunker once and for
all the next day at night they cuddle
together and fall asleep what they do
not realize is that the air duct of the
bunker has been blocked and there is no
oxygen left inside simone passes out but
rasmus wakes up at the right time and
drags her outside it is then revealed
that the blockage of the air ducts
wasn't a coincidence a group of
survivors saw simone yesterday and
messed with the bunker's outdoor panel
they gunned down the siblings and locked
them inside a room the leader reveals
they are there for food but rasmus and
simone have eaten almost all of the
stock by now after discovering that
nothing else is left in the bunker for
them they start to leave if they do
simone and rasmus will remain locked
inside the room until their deaths in a
desperate attempt to stop them simone
tells the leader martin that she knows
the location of the other bunkers where
the food might be available martin has
to include the brother and sister in his
group now that they are an asset the duo
finds out from the group that more than
90 percent of people in the world are
dead and the remaining are fighting for
their lives they kill and get killed for
food which is the only form of currency
in today's world a flashback shows us
how martin survived the first rainfall
he was in the military group that was
supposed to guard the borders to keep
the city quarantined
one day after the rainfall he was
guarding a bridge when a woman with her
infant in her arms tried to cross it he
was supposed to shoot her dead but he
could not do it as a result she infected
his fellow soldiers and only he survived
in the end then he joined forces with
another guy named patrick and the two
started looking for food and shelter one
day the duo found a group of three it
consisted of their leader beatrice and
two of her friends they promised to show
them the way to get more food and joined
their gang however to stay in the gang
beatrice provided sexual favors to
martin back in the present the gang is
on their way to the second bunker
although simone is leading the way the
others do not trust her just yet rasmus
and beatrice talk for a while and find
out a lot about each other even in this
situation rasmus is just happy to see
the sky and the trees after so long
suddenly they see a vehicle on the
street and hide two armed men come out
of the vehicle and martin is told that
they are unknown people who kidnap the
survivors before they can find the group
a girl running towards the forest
catches their attention when the men are
distracted the group tries to run away
but simone stops everyone she wants to
save the poor girl who needed their help
beatrice takes her side and martin has
to reluctantly oblige even though it is
a stupid plan and a pointless one a
while later they find the girl inside a
puddle even though she was able to lose
those men the puddle water is
contaminated which means she is bound to
die from the virus martin shoots her
dead to end her misery sooner rasmus and
simone are shocked but they try to
compromise with the new way of life they
stay at a building for the night where
one of the members named leia takes a
rest because she is ill rasmus is made
to wear shoes worn by a decaying corpse
he is lucky to have found them because
they are a hundred percent waterproof at
night simone falls asleep but rasmus has
a hard time closing his eyes he walks
around the building and finds beatrice
having sex with martin he feels a pang
of jealousy because he had started to
like her the following day they continue
towards the second bunker on the way
rasmus accidentally steps in water
martin brings out his gun to kill him
but is stopped by simone fortunately for
rasmus his waterproof shoes saved him
why isn't everyone wearing those
following the incident they finally
reached the bunker and it is opened
using simone's fingerprint inside they
find an entire pantry full of food the
group hasn't seen so much food in years
and is overjoyed at the site it will be
at least two weeks before they start
killing each other over this right then
simone notices a phone in one of the
rooms it used to belong to her father
which means he was in this bunker years
ago she finds a video on the phone from
frederick's boss asking him to come to
apollon headquarters in sweden he also
says that only frederick can find a cure
for the virus simone shows the video to
martin asking him to accompany the
siblings to sweden however since they
have security and food in the bunker
martin refuses even though there is a
possibility of them finding the cure as
a result rasmus and simone leave without
the rest of the group a while later
beatrice wakes up from her nap and finds
out the two left she wishes martin
farewell and leaves to look for them
with leia and the other member of the
group gene martin and his friend patrick
are left behind in the bunker which
martin is not happy about why doesn't he
leave then the rest of the group meets
at the border of the city of copenhagen
and makes their way forward they enjoy
each other's company and are happy to be
together after walking for an hour they
sit down to rest and eat gene and leia
go to a nearby eyewear store to get him
a new pair of glasses in their absence
the others are attacked by burglars
looking to rob their food they run away
but simone is separated from beatrice
and rasmus in the process she ends up in
an unknown part of the city where she
meets a little boy suddenly it starts to
rain so they take shelter in a building
when he starts taking random pills for a
stomachache simone offers him some food
suddenly they're approached by his
father who sees simone as a threat she
assures him she is not a bad person and
offers them more packaged food when the
rainfall stops the father and son walk
outside and are jumped by a group of
thugs simone wants to help them but
knows that it would be foolish so
instead she says nope and runs away
somewhere else rasmus and beatrice reach
a neighborhood where beatrice was born
they also happened to take shelter in
her childhood home she hadn't come here
since the first reign so seeing her
parents corpses huddled up on the bed is
horrifying to her rasmus helps her cope
with the situation and chats with her as
a distraction when the rain stops they
go back to the place they separated from
the rest of the group earlier simone is
also there and the group reunites but
trouble arises when they are yet again
attacked by a thug who followed simone
he holds rasmus hostage asking them to
hand over the food martin and patrick
arrive with guns just at the right time
they also wanted to be with the rest of
the group at the end of the day still
the thug manages to stab rasmus and run
away simone remembers there is another
bunker nearby and begs martin to bring
rasmus to it they can use medicines in
the bunker to help him the group
selflessly wheels rasmus to the bunker
but finds it in shambles they dress his
wound to the best of their abilities and
save him in a flashback we are shown
martin beatrice and their group hunting
for food beatrice shows him a small
house and says that it was her childhood
home it is clear that she lied to both
of them and is hiding something from
everyone in the last scene martin shows
simone a device they found in the last
bunker the device depicts a map of the
city that consists of a wall that was
not present before the outbreak martin
thinks the wall exists because the other
side is not affected by the virus this
means they still have a chance to
survive
to know what happens to them next watch
the second part in our new channel
series recapped